qui ont engendré 2,5 milliards $
en dépenses directes.
Louis-Philippe Ouimet.
- À Montréal, Grandé Studio
a accueilli l'an passé
la méga-production "Moonfall" et
c'est dans les studios de MELS
qu'a été filmé le prochain
"Transformers". Visiblement,
l'industrie du cinéma a roulé à
plein régime en 2021 au Québec.
Martin Carrier
Président de MELS
- C'était à peu près du jamais
vu, en effet. C'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est venu
chercher presque chaque morceau
d'équipement qui était
sur les tablettes.
- Il y a dix ans,
les productions étrangères
et le secteur effets spéciaux
ont généré au total
292 millions $. Après le sommet
de 2019, il y a eu nouveau
record en 2021, avec un total de
1,42 milliard de dépenses
directes.
CHRISTINE MAESTRACCI, Bureau du
cinéma et de la télévision, Qc
- On les qualifie d'années
historiques. Effectivement,tive,
tous les indicateurs sont à la
hausse au niveau de
la production de services,
donc l'accueil des tournages
étrangés, les effets visuels et
l'animation.
- Le deux-tiers de ces revenus
de l'étranger pour cette année
ue proviennent du
secteur des effets spéciaux.
Un des cofondateurs
de Grandé Studios est
présentement à Los Angeles pour
vanter les mérites de Montréal.
IOHANN MARTIN,
cofondateur de Grandé Studios
- On peut dire, là, qu'on a
démarré, on a démarré...
il y a quelque chose qui a
démarré, il y a un certain
momentum, donc il faut juste
maintenir ce momentum puis
s'assurer que 2022 suive 2021
puis c'est là où on va pouvoirst
un engouement.
- Si l'année 2021 aura été
faste, il faudra composeromposer
en 2022 avec la pénurie
de la main-d'oeuvre.
CHRISTIAN LEMAY,
Président AQTIS 514-AIEST
- L'impact d'une année record,
c'est sûr qu'il y a une
multiplication d'emplois créés.
Puis notre industrie, comme vous
le savez, il y a eu plusieurs
reportages à ce sujet-là,
on parlait de pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre, mais
c'est un beau problème.
- Malgré la concurrence
de Toronto et de Vancouver,
Montréal demeure une destination
de choix pour les producteurs
hollywoodiens.
- Dans les dernières donnée
qu'on a reçues, entre autres,
du palmarès de Best movie places
for Movie Makers, Montréal se
classe quatrième au palmarès des
villes, donc tout juste dern
Atlanta, Toronto et Alberkurque.
Donc c'est une bonne nouvelle
tréal.
- Soulignons que
les tournages locaux ont aussi
progressé pendant l'année 2021
en partie grâce aux subventions
accordées en cette période
de pandémie.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Mon